بالفعل وصلت هذه الطائره الثالثه من الجسر
الجوي السعودي الذي تم تسييره يوم الامس
وهي الطائره الثالثه التي تحمل على متنها
104 اطنان من المساعدات وصلت بالفعل ويتم
انزال هذه المساعدات مباشره من قبل
السلطات المطار التركي مطار غازي عنتاب
هذه المساعدات مباشره تذهب الى الشاحنات
ويتم توزيعها على في الاماكن
مخصصه والاماكن التي تم الاتفاق على
توزيعها من جانب المركز الملك سلمان
والسلطات التركيه بالاضافه الى جانب جزء
اخر والعدد ضخم جدا كما تشاهدين طائره
كبيره جدا وعلامتها 104 اطنان فبالتالي
هنالك جزء من هذه المساعدات كبير سيذهب
الى الداخل السوري وتحديدا الاماكن
المتاثره بهذه بهذا الزلزال هذه المساعدات
مباشره ستنطلق عبر متعهدين ومنظمات
دوليه وايضا باشراف مباشر من مركز الملك
سلمان عبر المنافذ التركيه السوريه
وتحديدا نتحدث عن منفذ منفذ انطاكيا
والمنفذ الاخر الذي منفذ باب الهوى
والمنفذ الاخر الذي سيتم استخدامه لايصال
هذه المساعدات مباشره المساعدات تحتوي على
اجهزه او مساعدات ايوائيه ومساعدات غذائيه
وطبيه ايضا بالاضافه الى ملابس شتويه
بالاضافه الى
مساعدات غذائيه وتحدث عن الغذاء الذي يكفي
هذه الاسر التي تفيد في العراق في ايام
طويله حتى تنتهي هذه الازمه ويتم ايضا
استمراريه هذه المساعدات عبر هذا الجسر
الجوي الذي يستمر
لم يتم تحديد وقت في الحقيقه لانتهاء هذا
الجسم بل سيستمر مادام هنالك حاجه بحسب
هذه المعطيات
ايضا قبل ان اختم
فاطمه في الجزء الاخر من المطار وهذه
الحاله هنا حيث الطائرات تصل من مختلف
انحاء العالم مركز الملك سلمان بجانبه
ايضا طائره اخرى للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
والتي يصل على متنها تقريبا
خمسين فرد من من افراد الانقاذ ومن
الدفاع المدني الذين سيقومون بعمليات
الانقاذ من السودان الذين وصلوا الى هذه
المنطقه لمساعده السلطات التركيه في مناطق
مختلفه
وسيباشرون ايضا مع المساعدات الاخرى التي
ستصل بشكل مباشر من مختلف انحاء العالم